you know there's a saying
even if you are next to a river of water
save each drop because you don't know
whether there will be a drop tomorrow
the more people on earth
the less available water we're going to
have to drink
the most important thing
is to understand
the actual worth of water
the distances in the guru is immense
we travel 70 kilometers to get to
titicama village
this village relied only on rainwater
for eight long years
the impact on the communities in the
guru is severe
and the people are really suffering
there is no water but we need to save
lives and the only way to do that is to
find alternative sources of water to
rain water we can only find that water
in the underground aquifers that's the
only water available will be under the
ground about a hundred and eighty
million years ago volcanoes erupted in
the area of tetsukama and i can then see
on google the lines where these
volcanoes erupted and then we drill into
the fault zone that can be as tiny as
three centimeter wide we also use a
traditional methodology and that is to
detect these differences in the
electromagnetic field of the earth
methodologies that was used for ages and
ages by our grandfathers to be able to
pump water from the land
blood
stock
samples
dimensional cycle metabolism
on smooth work mentors will demand some
help
i've got a really strong emotional
connection with the river it really does
reconnect you with
nature
the thames has gone from this
biologically dead zombie river to having
all this wildlife in it
there's 119 different species of fish
living in the river and about 80 species
of bird
it also provides tap water for around 7
million people in london
it's the archery of london
in 1858 the population of london was
about 2 million people
a sewage system had never been built up
to that point the river was full of raw
sewage it was just free flow into the
river it also meant that people were
getting really ill from cholera and
dying
parliament agreed to invest in a sewage
system
this victorian era sewage system
relieved the pressure on the river but
then in the second world war it was
bombed
by 1954 the river had deteriorated so
much
a survey by the natural history museum
had declared it as biologically
dead anywhere you go you're going to
find a body of water in florida
you have lagoons you have streams you
have rivers
we have a lot of natural springs here in
florida that maintain 70 degrees
and that's perfect for manatees
so manatees have been around the state
of florida for many years
they're just special
they love to eat seagrass they can eat
anywhere from 10 to 15
of their body weight
you can't see a manatee without smiling
they're adorable
in 2021 we lost over 1100 manatees in
one year
most of those deaths was due to
starvation and what we're finding is
we don't have the clean water to sustain
that food source
everything going into our waterways here
in florida back to that seagrass growing
pesticides
fertilizers things that people use to
have beautiful grass in their yards but
unfortunately it does come with a price
there's about a thousand people moving
here every day
we continue to
push those houses right up against the
waterways
all of that infrastructure is going to
have an effect on them
here at zootempo we work with several
different partners and we're all a part
of the manatee rescue and rehabilitation
partnership
and really the job is to ensure we're
putting all the resources to really
saving the species
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
today the thames is one of the cleanest
rivers in the world that runs through a
major city which is incredible given the
size of the population of london
so you've got things like shark coming
in
and sea horses you can find sea horses
and you've got grey seal and harbor seal
coming right up the river
[Music]
have a seal try to get on the kayak was
just magical
[Music]
over the last 60 years there's been
investment from the water treatment
companies there's also been legislation
by government when land is reclaimed and
re-wilded things like reed beds enable
the water that's come off the land come
off london and filter through those
plants and go in as clean water into the
river
there are still many issues with the
river there needs to be a lot more work
and investment into stopping that extra
sewage that would overflow going into
rivers
there's now a new huge sewer system
being put in place across 25 miles of
central london
hopefully this will have a really
positive impact on the river
the population of london is projected to
increase to 16 million that will then
put a huge amount of pressure on the
water sources and so we really do need
to conserve the water that we have
here at zootampo we are one of three
facilities that can actually take
injured manatees
we will actually
bring them to our critical care facility
and give them all the care that they
need
you know an animal that is underweight
we're looking to put hundreds of pounds
on that animal we're able to give them
that supportive care that they need
hopefully get them healthy and then send
them back out to the florida wild
[Music]
when we do these releases
we want to make sure that we're doing it
on a really cold day so that a lot of
animals are going to be around so that
hopefully that young animal will follow
those manatees and figure out where they
need to go to stay warm to find food
to be a part of that journey and to be
able to help them and know that
we're going to be able to get them to a
place where we can send them back home
it's a feeling you can't explain
if i look at the communities where we
work
we have a lot to learn from these people
these human beings can survive for a
week on 20 liters of drinking water
they save every single drop
now i think we as people living in
cities need to learn from that
[Music]
we as consumers can play a really
important part in protecting the river
we can do that by conserving water there
are so many ways that we can conserve
water just within our homes
if everybody does something it really
adds up when you've got a population the
size of nine million in london
just those little bits really make a
difference
it's really important for everyone to
help conserve water think about it in
your everyday actions when you brush
your teeth when you shower when you
clean your dishes are you rinsing those
dishes with water before you then put
them in your dishwasher
i think for everyone to conserve water
is to be mindful
we always think of nature separately
we are a part of it
three percent of all the water on earth
is fresh water most is locked up in ice
caps or underground aquifers
only 0.5 percent is available to the
growing human population
it's vital we all find ways to save this
precious resource
simple actions can help like turning the
tap off when brushing our teeth
taking shorter showers
installing dual flush toilets
and cutting out pre-rinsing when using
our dishwashers dishwashers and
detergents like finish work without the
need to pre-rinse with precious water
that could be preserved for nature if
all of us make simple changes in our
daily lives
we can conserve billions of liters of
water
that's why finnish are promoting one
simple yet effective action
skip the rinse
they're also helping protect fragile
waterways like the colorado river and
the freshwater ecosystems of east anglia
as well as working in south africa on a
range of projects to prevent day zero
from ever happening together
we can make every drop count
[Music]